hi guys my Justine for those of you that
don't know I'm in New York right now for
the VMAs I'll be your Twitter
correspondent for the free show so you
better tweet me and make my job a lot
easier but for now I'd love to share
with you guys some clips that I
accumulated throughout the day today
which consists of everything from me
finding a dress to shooting a ton of
backstage stuff which I was constantly
asking people can I shoot this are you
sure you don't mind me putting this
online and most of the time it was okay
so are you pretty busy busy this morning
yeah yeah yeah get the winner the rates
in real sexy I'm getting some coffee
here at this futuristic coffee machine
and it's telling me to enjoy my drink
thank you I will do that hello everyone
hope you guys are doing well I'm here in
Radio City where the actual event has
really taken place here on Sunday and
it's pretty crazy I've never been in
here before
I want to go talk to one of my special
friends and just met he's a great guy
he's Justin Justin mover I'm sitting
next to him
right here
right there at supper easy
so I'm going in to check out the cracks
so how they actually faker show
everything that you see on this room
I'm the creative producer which
basically means I worked on a lot the
screen that's in the house and also on
the nomination packages and the show
logo and just the digital identity of
the show in case you guys using L cell
for everything VMA related you can check
out intercom to find out more about what
I'm doing here at the VMAs you can
follow my Twitter hope you guys enjoyed
see you guys on Sunday so get tweeting